for joe ross it'll be the first time he
faces the tampa bay rays well hopefully
joe likes facing florida teams good
start last time against the marlins
because it has a good sinker slider
combination
here's wander franco
comes in three of 22.
and he shoots this one into left there's
a base hit toward the corner a backhand
by schwarber
and moving up and stopping at second
base is g-man choi and a good job by
schwarber out there in the left
national's over shift three man to the
right turners to the right of second
only castro on the left side of the
pitch swung on him popped up left field
and shallow schwarber is coming in and
he's there he makes the catch and there
are two men away and next up is the
third baseman joey wendell and a ball
driven to left schwarber to his right
a busy man in the inning be left-handed
rich hill making his 16th start of the
season how good he has been since the
beginning of may overall six and two
with the 3.52
kyle schwarber is one for nine career
against rich hill with three strikeouts
but we have found out lately it doesn't
matter if it's righty or lefty
the way he's going
oh my
i can't believe it
see
you
later
come on
there are no more get me over fastballs
to start baseball games than college
shorter's in an off spot
another elevated fastball
belt high
goodbye
434 feet
well here's juan soto he's going to get
one at home we're just waiting to see
when
soto checks one to right and it's
heading for the bullpen
c
u
later
yeah only a matter of time in the next
lead
three-nothing
well that ball got out in the heartbeat
frozen rope from juan soto 113 miles an
hour off the back and now zunino one of
the few right-handed hitters in the
lineup
nasty slider
joe russ first strikeout there's brett
phillips joe ross
with the slider
gets the knees
on the outside edge victor 245 with nine
walks over his last 20 ball games he
goes deep to left he has hasn't homered
this year but now he has
see
you later
gonna have to rename this place the
armory
which sits next door over at rfk
unbelievable victor finally checks into
the home run gulliver he's got power 17
home runs in 2019. well rich hill tagged
for four runs in the first two innings
he's due to lead off the third but not
happy
with his performance at this point you
know he is going to lead off a couple
extra swings there in the dugout before
he comes up
and look at that he puts down a bunt
pretty good one and the throw is going
to be wide now he's going to head to
second base and rich hill winds up at
second turning off to a rough start with
a bunt hit an error and a walk jammed
him into a fly ball to left
schwarber cruising to it
big out next up
the kid juan der franco doesn't want to
load them up for austin meadows
and that base hit no it's not a base
head
they're not going to turn two are they
no way maybe josh harrison's best play
of the year
selling out to his right to get a 4-6
first play on what looked like a sure
hit still trying to get out of this
inning there goes the runner ross to the
plate
and that his strike three called
fastball belt high meadows thought it
was high but he is rung up for strike
three and the inning is over here is
kevin kearmeyer he had to tap her back
to ross his first time up
wow
joe ross
fourth strikeout he's working fast the
rays are up there hacking next up the
catcher mike zanino
swing
and a miss on 95
upstairs
on a warm night joe ross is hot again
ross has thrown 46 pitches
and 30 strikes
another left-handed hitter jammed into
an easy fly ball and another one on one
pitch
schwarber puts it away it's two out
nobody on and we'll leave it for brandon
loud a four-nothing washington league
this one is swung out and skyed back
into deep center row blades gonna climb
the wall and that one is out of here
home run to center field off the bat of
brandon lau
and the rays get on the board
and brandon lau
has just hit his 16th home run
and it's a three-run ball game here's
one defranco's third at that base hit to
left and a ground ball looked like it
was a hit but josh harrison stole a hit
away from it
this one is starlin castro on the right
side
first pitch right side harrison across
his body runner to third on the second
out
and there's a base hit the other way
into left center here comes meadows and
the score keermeyer's gonna dig for two
and end
and the raves get their second run of
the night got a game situation on our
hands here in the sixth inning
swing
and a miss
always nice to have 95
to call off
so here's randy or rosarina
[Applause]
joe ross picking the best time of offer
strikeout number seven he'll go six and
a third another great outing for joe
ross tonight
now it's up to his buddies in the
bullpen now it's sam clay the nets need
a ground ball right at somebody here
leading by two
there's a chopper right at somebody
drake turner
he'll get the middle runner
so a key second out on the fielders
choice on a pitch away harrison waiting
for it
and a huge zero for the nats to put on
the board austin both for the nets here
we go top of the eighth austin meadows
their cleanup man in the air to center
it'll play for victor robles
huge out the wine by vote this will be a
payoff pitch in their strength recall
wendell throwing the bat away
and heading to first
as he's run up at a 95 mile an hour
fastball at the knees to the outside
part of the play
bouncer right side josh harrison
the bullpen
keeps coming up large even if the names
are not
the stars
so it could be an interesting ninth
inning here for the rays
there's a high
fly ball back into deep left down the
line schwaber into foul territory
and that ball is going to be gone i
think it hit the pole so that makes it a
four to three ball game annette scored
four runs
after eight batters tonight and they've
been trying to hold on ever since line
drive right field one soto
game over